[MUSIC PLAYING]
AKSHAY KANNAN: Good
morning, everyone.
Ooh, first talk of the day.
So hi.
I'll start by
introducing ourselves.
My name is Akshay Kannan.
And I'm a Product Manager
on the Android Auth team.
FELIPE LEME: I'm Felipe Leme.
I'm Software Engineer in
Android Frameworks Team.
SIMRANJIT KOHLI: Hi,
I'm Simranjit Kohli.
I am Software Engineer in
Android Authentication Team.
AKSHAY KANNAN: And our talk
is all about Android APIs
that you can use to
improve sign-in, payment,
and other key forms and
experiences in your apps.
So let's dive right in.
Why are we giving this talk?
What are the goals we want
to accomplish with this?
The first is to get more apps to
use existing data from Android,
and to avoid
prompting your users.
Throwing up any kind of
blank form in your app,
such as an app log-in
or a credit card,
can create friction
and result in drop-off
when users don't know
this information offhand.
We've created APIs for
you to automatically get
this information
when it's available
so that you can let your
users skip past this step
and get right to the stuff that
actually matters in your app.
Secondly, we'll
talk about how you
can provide a
seamless experience
and reduce churn when
your users switch devices.
Getting a new phone is awesome.
But it can also mean that
your users get locked out of
or stop engaging with your app.
Here also, we have a set of
APIs to maintain your app state
across devices.
Let's start by
focusing on how you
can use existing information
that the user has already
provided to enhance your flows.
The first feature I want
to talk about is a new one.
You may have heard about
this in the Keynote.
Starting in Android O,
we've added native support
for password managers.
This functionality is
integrated tightly into the OS.
So you don't have to rely
on hacks like Accessibility
Services or Custom
Keyboards in order
to securely fill in
passwords, credit
cards, and other information.
We've partnered with DashLane,
LastPass, Keeper, and 1Password
to support this feature when
Android O goes out this year.
And we're really
excited about this.
Of course, not everyone
uses a password manager.
But we still want
all Android O users
to be able to
experience the security
and convenience of Autofill.
So for those users,
we're introducing
Autofill with Google.
This feature comes bundled
with Android O devices
and lets you fill in passwords,
addresses, credit cards
and other information
that you already
have saved to your
Google account
with Chrome Sync, all
with a single tap.
We've made a preview of this
feature available to developers
as part of the O beta, which
you can play around with today,
and use to test out
functionality for autofilling
the logins in your apps.
Support for credit
cards and addresses
is coming later this year,
along with a consumer release.
Let's take a look at
what this looks like.
Let's cut to the demo.
So let's say that I'm logging
into Twitter on a new device.
I simply open the app.
I tap Log in.
And you can see here,
that my username already
auto-populates as a suggestion.
I simply tap on that.
My Username and Password
automatically get filled in.
I hit Log in.
And now, as you
can see, I've been
able to log into
Twitter without pressing
a single key on my phone.
Next, I'll hand
things over to Felipe,
who's going to talk a little
bit about how this all works
and how you can optimize
your apps as developers
for Autofill.
FELIPE LEME: Thanks, Akshay.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, the clap was for him
or for Autofill with Google.
But pretty sure
it was not for me.
Anyway.
So the Android
Autofill framework
was designed to work out of
the box with existing apps,
without changing the apps
to support the Autofill.
In fact, for our Twitter
demo, we just got a Twitter.
We just installed our
existing Twitter app
from the Google Play Store.
And it just worked,
without any involvement
for the Twitter developers.
We hope this is going to
be the case for most apps.
But we still provide
some API's that you
can use to make sure that
your app integrates well
with Autofill.
We'll see some of these
API's over the next slides.
But first, let's take a
high-level look on how Autofill
works, because that
will make it easier
to understand why using
these API's is important.
So the Autofill workflow
involves three processes.
In one hand, you
have our app, which
is the app, being Autofill.
In the other hand, you
have Autofill service,
which is the app that
has the user data,
like a Password Manager,
or Autofill with Google.
Then in between then, you have
the Android Runtime System,
which is a mediator used
for privacy, security,
and performance reasons.
The whole workflow starts
when the user selects
an editable field on the app.
For example, when the Username
view on Twitter was focused.
So at that point, there
is an Autofill [? infra ?]
running on the app the process.
And that [? infra ?] is
going to create a customized
version of the very structure
that is optimized for Autofill.
Then it will send this view
structure back to the Android
system, where the Android
system will sanitize the data
by stripping out sensitive
[? valleys. ?] Next,
the Android system sends the
data to the Autofill service.
Now, here is the part where
things got interesting
from an API point of view.
The Autofill service will
parse this view's structure,
and will look for fields
that can be autofilled.
Then it will look on the
user data for that app
and see if there is a match.
If there is a match, then it
creates another data structure
called data set.
And sends that data set
over to the Android system.
At this point,
the Android system
is able to Autofill your app.
But it doesn't do that
without the user confirmation.
So what it does instead, it
shows an Autofill dialog,
with the Options
sent by the service.
And only after the
user selects an Option,
we send that data
set back to the app.
And then the Autofill
infrastructure,
we will automatically
set the views
and change the
background colors to show
that the view was Autofilled.
So this workflow
works pretty fast.
It's pretty fast.
Like we saw in the demo,
the Autofill dialog
comes out almost at the same
time as the keyboard itself.
But this workflow has a catch.
It only works if the Autofill
service can figure out what
can be autofilled in your app.
Generally speaking, the password
managers have good heuristics,
And they can pretty
much figure out
how to Autofill almost any app.
But they don't want to
rely only on the heuristics
to make it work.
It's better if you
can tell them for sure
what can be Autofilled
on their app and how.
It's also nice to help the
Android system to optimize
the workflow by
telling which fields
should be ignored because
they don't make sense
to be Autofilled.
You can accomplish
both these goals
by simply annotating our
active XML with Autofill text,
as we're going to see
on the next slide,
using a very simple
log-in screen example.
So this log-in screen has
three editable fields.
There is a Username and Password
and a CAPTCHA challenge.
The Username and
Password are the fields
that really make sense
to be Autofilled,
while the CAPTCHA is something
the user has to type in
to prove that the user is
a human being, or a tree,
in this case, and not a robot.
So without further ado,
let's take a look at the XML.
The first and most
important tag you can use,
it's called Autofill hints.
This tag tells the
Autofill service
what is the meaning of our
view, or what kind of user
information that the service
can use to fill your view.
For example, on
our password field,
there is only one way to
fill that info, which it
is using the user's password.
So we say out Autofill
hints equals password.
But on our username, our
app allows either a Username
or email address.
But we don't know in
advance which of these two
informations the
Autofill service it has.
So it's better to give the
Autofill service a choice.
So we put all values
that are possible here.
So we say Username,
email address.
The Autofill hints
can take any string.
You can have
something as bizarre
as my dog's favorite color
while on vacation in California,
last year, during the drought.
But these hints are only useful
if the service understand
what they mean.
So we provide the
constants in view.java
for the most common cases
like Username, Email Address,
Telephone Number, Credit Card
number, Credit Card Expiration
Date.
So it's better if you try to
use this constant as that.
The next tag is called
Important for Autofill.
This tag is used by
the Android system
to optimize the workflow.
So basically, it tells
the Android system
whether the view should
trigger the Autofill workflow,
and whether the
contents of the view
should be included in
the view structure that's
sent over to the service.
So in our example, we can
mark the CAPTCHA editor
test important for
Autofill equals no.
That means that when the
Autofill workflow is triggered
by the Username and Password,
we don't send the CAPTCHA over.
So this might sound like a
small, minor improvement.
But remember, this is running
on our mobile environment, where
every little
optimization counts.
In fact, there
might be cases where
the whole activity doesn't
make sense to be Autofilled.
For example, in a
spreadsheet editor
like the one in Google Drive.
In this case, you can mark
the root view of your activity
with an importantForAutoFill
equals noExcludeDescendants.
And that pretty much is
telling the Android system
that no view inside
the directive
should automatically
trigger Autofill.
Just keep in mind that
an important for Autofill
is an optimization hint, another
way to effectively disable
Autofill on your app.
The user can always bypass
your decision, your hint,
by manually requesting Autofill.
For example, the user can
long-press the Edit Text,
and then select the Autofill
option in the Overflow menu.
And when that happens, not only
will it trigger the Autofill
workflow, but it will send
over all views, including
those marked as not important.
So this is pretty much
the two easiest ways
you can optimize your
apps for Autofill.
There are other tags and
Java API's that you can use.
But we didn't have time to
show in the presentation.
But they are available on
the official documentations,
on the official docs
for the Autofill.
Now, back to Akshay,
for more tips.
AKSHAY KANNAN: Thanks, Felipe.
As we mentioned earlier, along
with introducing the Autofill
framework in Android, we're
launching our own Autofill
service that comes bundled
with O Devices, Autofill
with Google.
Of the nice things about
Autofill with Google
is that your data is synced
between the Chrome browser
and the mobile
apps that you use.
In order for this
to work, you need
to claim the association
between your mobile app
and your website.
And you can do this using
digital asset linking.
If you've used other things
like App Linking in Android,
you might be familiar
with this already.
Basically, for Autofill,
this enables any web logins
that are saved using Chrome to
work with mobile apps and vice
versa.
And basically, in order to
make this association work,
there's just two steps involved.
So the first step is to host
some JSON on your web server,
at yourdomain/.well
known./assetlinks.json.
And this tells us
about the mobile apps
that are associated
with your domain,
along with the
permissions that you
want to share with those apps.
Here, you explicitly
define the permissions
that you want to have shared.
So in this case on
the slide, there is
the common.get_login_creds
permission,
which enables your credentials
to be shared from your website
to your mobile app.
In addition to
credential sharing,
there's many other
permissions that you can also
grant to your app
using the same JSON.
For example, there's also the
Handle All URLs permission,
which lets your app handle
incoming web links via app
linking, so that your users
can seamlessly open links
that your app was
designed to handle.
The next step, once
you've hosted this JSON
on your server, is to define
the corresponding association
in your mobile app.
And you can do this by
modifying your apps manifest.
To enable credential
sharing, you
need to add the following
metadata tag to your manifest.
Here, Android string
assets statements
points to a JSON
string resource that
contains a list of web
targets and permissions,
similar to what you
hosted on your web site.
And that's it.
With these two
steps, you can share
credentials between your web
site and your mobile app.
This works for Autofill.
And it also works for
Smart Lock for Passwords,
which lets you automatically
sign in your users.
Now, I'm going to
hand things over
to Simranjit, who's going
to talk more about how
you can enable Automatic
Sign-in for your users
in further detail.
SIMRANJIT KOHLI: Thanks, Akshay.
We want our users to get as
much value out of their device
as quickly as possible.
A lot of that value is
associated with their accounts.
So we have provided
a set of APIs
to make user log-ins
easy and seamless.
The first one is Smart
Lock for Passwords,
which was introduced last year.
The second one is
Account Transfer API,
which will be released in an
upcoming Google Play Services
update.
There are benefits
to each of them
that we look at as we move on.
The first API we discuss here
is Smart Lock for Passwords.
It allows for automatic sign-in
and skipping password forms
completely.
It syncs with passwords stored
in users' Chrome profile.
As a result, it persists
across app installs.
It has some differences
from Autofill.
While Autofill is only support
supported Android O onwards,
Smart Lock is backward
compatible with ICS,
and delivered via
Google Play Services.
With Smart Lock,
users can be logged
into your app programmatically
without any user input.
Here, as you can see in the
Netflix example on the slide,
user did not have
to do anything.
They just opened
their Netflix app.
Netflix makes the API call,
gets the credential result,
verifies the credential
with the server,
and signs-in a
user automatically.
In this case, log-in screen
can be skipped completely.
With Autofill, user at least
has to tap into the fields
in order to populate them.
Smart Lock also provides
advanced security feature.
There are two major
flows associated
with this API, retrieving
credentials and saving
credentials.
Here's how to retrieve
credentials using the Request
API.
If the credential was
already available,
you get success on the callback.
And you can sign-in
user immediately,
as was shown in the Netflix
example in the previous slide.
The other cases
require user action,
which are triggered by
launching relevant intent.
If the user has
multiple credentials,
they can pick the
credential they want to use.
If there are no
credential available,
they get a dialog to select
email address or phone number
to sign-in or sign-up with.
Here's an example of a save API.
If the credentials were
already saved previously,
and you are making a
call to updating them,
the callback results
in a success.
But to save a new
password, the user
must give consent for the
credential to be saved.
In this scenario, you have
to call start resolution
for result.
Additionally, the responses
from Smart Lock API
also includes a signed
JSON web ID token,
if Google has verified
the user's email address.
You can use this
token on your server
to verify user's email
address, and sign them
in without a password.
Or you can use it as a
strong positive signal
in anti-abuse algorithms.
Also, check out the talk
later today on phone auth,
which will cover a new
Smart Lock API to verify
phone numbers via SMS messages.
Now, let's talk about a second
API, the Account Transfer API.
While setting up your
new Android device,
you might have seen
the following flow,
where it gives you an
option to copy your data
from your existing phone.
Initially, introduced a tap
and go in Lollipop release,
this flow allows you to
copy your Google accounts
from your existing device
to your new device.
We thought about how we can make
it more seamless for our users
to get started on
their new device.
And we came up with
Account Transfer API
to help transfer
non-Google accounts also
during the setup process.
After you select
that you are copying
your data from another
device, our flow kicks in.
As you saw in the
previous slide,
Account Transfer API
transfers credentials
during the setup of the device.
It's a device to
device transfer.
Some organizations
don't allow the storage
of the users' credentials
on their servers,
due to the nature of
their security policy.
So in that case, this
API is very useful.
Also, there is no dependency
on Google accounts.
If you are an identity
provider, this API
provides a lot of benefits.
It is only available to
Android authenticators.
Authenticators are apps which
implement Android Account
Authenticator, and integrate
with account manager
on the Android platform.
Account Transfer API
provides an encrypted channel
between participating
authenticators
on a user's existing
and new device.
This encrypted
pipe is established
by Google Play Services,
running on both these devices.
Apps can do two-way
communication
over this encrypted
channel, if they are also
present on the new device.
But if the app is not
present on the new device,
transfer credentials are
held in temporary storage.
If your app is pre-installed
on the new device,
here is how it looks.
You can send
messages from source
to target, and from
target to source,
establishing a
two-way communication.
You can perform key exchanges or
perform cryptographic challenge
response flows.
Google Play Services
running onboard
these devices notifies you of
available data on that device
by a broadcast.
However, if your app is not
installed on the target device,
the credentials sent from your
app on the source to the target
are stored in temporary storage.
When your app gets installed,
and is open for the first time,
make a call to our
API to retrieve
the transferred-over
credentials.
To participate in
this API, you need
to register these
broadcasts in your manifest.
This slide shows
which broadcasts
are active on the
source and which
ones are active on the target.
If your app doesn't come
pre-installed on any OEM system
image, you only need
START_ACCOUNT_EXPORT broadcast.
Here is a sample code that will
be called on your users' source
device.
When source-side
broadcast is triggered,
you should start a new service.
In the service, you first get
a handle to the API object.
And then send the user
credentials in byte format,
using the same data API.
In case there is a failure,
notify about it to our API.
On the target side,
you can retrieve
the data that was sent over.
Here also, when your
broadcast is triggered,
you should start a service.
In the service,
grab the API object.
And then make the
retrieve data API call
and retrieve the byte data
that was transferred over.
Convert this byte data to your
credentials using your custom
logic.
And then add the account on the
device using Account Manager
API.
Finally, notify our API
about success or failure.
This is a simplistic
example, where
only one-way communication
is happening.
Source sends the data
and target retrieves it.
This is sufficient
for many apps,
like apps managing email,
IMAP, POP3 accounts.
The same code can be
used if the app is not
installed on the target,
and when the user opens
the app for the first time.
However, in this case,
you can send the data back
to the source.
Also, make sure not to call
this API from your main thread.
Now I will hand it over to
Akshay to discuss Android Pay
and Backup API's.
AKSHAY KANNAN:
Thanks, Simranjit.
So in the last few
slides, you learned about
how you can
automatically sign users
in using Smart
Lock for Passwords,
or how you can securely
transfer credentials
from your old device to your
new device using the upcoming
Account Transfer API.
Similarly, for Payments
also, we offer a set of APIs
to help you get this
information automatically,
on behalf of the user.
And similarly, this also extends
down to older Android versions.
So you don't have to
depend on your users
running Autofill on Android O.
Currently, we have the
Android Pay API today, which
gives you Android Pay Cards.
But as you heard in
the payment session,
we'll be introducing the Google
Payments API in the coming
weeks to extend this API to
include all of the cards tied
to a user's Google account,
not just the ones that they
have using Android Pay.
And best of all, there's
no commission or fees
involved at all in
using any of these APIs.
To make this work, there's
basically three steps involved.
First thing you do, is
you request MaskedWallet.
And that shows a dialog similar
to the one in the screenshot
you can see on the slide.
And this lets the user
pick a form of payment.
Once they've selected one,
you can handle the response
from this, and use that to
present a final confirmation
to your user, confirming
the amount, what they're
going to be ordering,
and the method of payment
they selected.
And then once the
user confirms this,
you can request a Full Wallet.
And what that does is that
gives you the credentials
that you need to
complete the transaction.
So that's it for payment API's.
So in the whole first
part of this presentation,
we've talked a lot about
using existing information
that the user
already has provided
to speed up critical forms
and flows in your apps.
Whether it's logins, or
payments, or anything else.
In the second part, we're
going to focus on using backup
and restore to reduce churn
when your users switch devices,
or if they reinstall their
app on the same device.
Even if someone's
using a new device,
our goal is to make it
feel like they never
stopped using your app.
So as we mentioned before,
throwing up a blank login
screen the first time
an existing user uses
your app on a new device
can create unnecessary churn
and stop users from reengaging.
If they've already
used your app,
you can skip your welcome
flow, pre-populate
log-in information, and
transfer over settings
and any other states to give
your users a warm welcome and a
seamless transition
onto their new device.
The goal is to preserve as much
of your app state as possible
so that your users
continue to stay engaged.
We offer two API's
for doing this.
There is the Auto
Backup API, which,
as you'll see in the next
slide, is extremely low effort
for developers.
It's basically a line of code
that you add to your manifest.
And it backs up everything
in your app, wholesale.
For a more fine-grain
control over exactly what
gets backed up in
your app, we recommend
using Key/Value Backup.
This works on Froyo and above.
So pretty much all
active Android devices
today are supported, assuming
a user has Backup turned on.
We'll talk through
both of these API's.
We'll explain how you use
them, and talk through some
of the trade-offs between them.
Let's start by talking
about the Auto Backup API.
As we mentioned
in the last slide,
it's extremely low effort for
developers to add to your app.
You just add this single
line to your manifest
that you can see on the
slide, and everything
gets backed up wholesale,
including shared preferences,
your files, and your databases.
In addition, you can also define
custom XML include and exclude
rules to control exactly
what gets backed up.
All of this data gets
persisted in a private folder
in the users' Google
Drive account,
which is limited to 25
megabytes per user, per app.
This doesn't count towards
the users' Drive storage.
And only the most recent
backup ever gets stored.
So every time
there's a new backup,
it overrides the
previous backup.
That being said, auto backup
is limited to Marshmallow
and above.
And if you want broader support,
or more fine-grained control
over exactly what
gets backed up,
you're going to want to use the
Key/Value Backup API instead.
The Android Key/Value Backup
lets you preserve your app data
by uploading it to
Android's backup service.
The amount of data is limited
to five megabytes per user,
per app, and it's available
completely free of charge.
There's basically two
steps to make this work.
You update your
manifest, and then you
write the code to do the backup.
In the first step, where
you update your manifest,
you want to point to the backup
agent, which in this case,
is my backup agent, which
we'll define in the next slide.
And you want to register for
the Android Backup Service
in the API console, which gives
you an API key that you can
Copy/Paste into your manifest.
Next, once you've
updated your manifest,
you want to actually
define your backup agent.
And this is the code that
actually does the backup.
In most cases, rather than
extending BackupAgent directly,
you can extend
BackupAgentHelper,
and use the two included helpers
that we've already provided,
which are the Shared Preferences
Backup Helper for backing up
shared preferences, and the
FileBackupHelper for backing up
files.
In the right, you can
look at an example
of what this looks like.
Basically, in the
onCreate method
of your BackupAgentHelper,
you can instantiate
one of these helpers
with the name of the file
that you want to back up.
And then you call
the addHelper method,
which adds this helper to
your BackupAgentHelper.
If you need further control
over versioning, file portions,
or databases, you can extend
the BackupAgent directly,
rather than using
our included helpers.
So that's Backup and Restore.
In this whole talk,
we've discussed
a lot of API's to help
you streamline your apps,
ranging from logins, to credit
cards, to Backup and Restore.
Our vision with these
API's is to lower
the barrier for
new users, and even
existing users on an
old device, to start
interacting with and
engaging with your app.
We want to move to a world in
which your phone knows more
about you, and it can provide
this information to other apps
when you allow that information
to be provided to them.
We want to make forms
a thing of the past.
And as app
developers, you should
be able to tap into information
that's already been provided
by the user, rather than forcing
them to type it over and over
again just so you can get it.
Especially with instant
apps, upfront forms
can significantly
hurt the experience
and increase the friction that's
needed to try something new.
So our goal with these
APIs is for mundane stuff
like credential entry to
become a thing of the past.
And if the user
purchases a new device,
we want this information to stay
with them and move with them,
so they don't feel like they're
starting all over again.
So just to recap the key
takeaways from the whole talk,
first and foremost, Autofill
is coming with Android O,
as you saw in the demo.
Please optimize your
apps for Autofill.
You can annotate your
XML using the hints
that Felipe talked about.
And also, you can
use Digital Asset
Linking to associate your
website and your mobile app,
so that credentials can
be seamlessly shared
between the two.
Second, populate credentials
and payment information
automatically when
it's available.
You can use the Smart
Lock API to backup
your username and password
associated with Chrome Sync.
You can use the Android
Account Transfer API
if you need a secure and
encrypted pipe during device
setup.
And you can use the
Android Pay API's today,
and the Google Payment's
API's in the coming weeks
to get payment
information from the user
without any sort of commission.
And thirdly, make
sure you persist
your apps' data across devices.
We talked about the
Auto Backup API's,
which is extremely low
effort and backs up
pretty much everything
in your app.
And for more fine-grain
control, we also
offer a Key/Value Backup.
So this was a lot of APIs
that we talked about today.
We have a short link
here on the slide
that takes you to a doc,
where we've provided links
to the developer documentations
for each of these APIs
so you can learn more.
Thank you so much for
coming out to our talk.
Hopefully, you'll check
these APIs out and use them
in your apps.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]